welcome to film courage this is episode
155 I'm Karen warden and I'm David
Brannon you can find our archives on
iTunes film curse calm la talk radio com
and movie garage today's guests are
documentarians Audrey you'll and Aaron
eights founders of ninety-nine percent
the Occupy Wall Street collaborative
film 99% the Occupy Wall Street
collaborative film is a documentary film
project founded by multiple independent
filmmakers working in conjunction across
the country they've come together and
pledged their time skills and gear to
document the events which recently took
place in new york city and across
america with the Occupy Wall Street
movement they invite you to do it with
them as the Occupy Wall Street movement
continues the protests began in
September of 2011 in lower Manhattan and
spread nationwide as momentum furthered
many involved complain that media is
failing in their coverage the filmmakers
are calling for others to join them in
documenting the wall street movement
currently Audrey and Aaron are raising
money for the project via IndieGoGo you
can check out the campaign by visiting
indiegogo com / 99 film in addition to
99 percent Audrey and Aaron are the
award-winning directors producers of the
internationally theatrically distributed
feature until the light takes us a doc
about Norwegian black metal a violent
music subculture and are currently
working on a narrative thriller dark
places please welcome to film courage
via telephone filmmakers Audrey you'll
and Aaron eights welcome both hello
Isaac ravenous yeah thank you thank you
so much for being here you can file
follow Audrey and Aaron on Twitter at
Audrey you'll and at erin eights and
that's a AR 0 n AI te s and you can also
follow their film 99 underscore film all
on twitter yeah so let's find out how
did the Occupy Wall Street movement
begin for I don't want to foul
and I'm with a huge but yeah we're just
editing the explanation for that in the
ether room as we speak mobile perfect
okay so you like mine's okay um well as
you mean the actual you're the actual
movement for this for those that then
know that are sort of in the dark about
it have you seen it on the news but they
don't really know what it's about and
how did it begin and then we'll go into
where is it right now and then where is
it going okay well so the first thing
that probably we should say is that we
are not part of the Occupy movement ok
we are independently covering it without
being directly affiliated and so we have
about a hundred people working on the
film right now all over the country and
and some of them many of them do
identify as part of the movement but a
lot of people also do not they're very
interested just covering it from a more
objective space so when I talk about the
movement itself I always I just have to
say and this is funny actually because
I'm actually now repeating what people
in the movement actually say hey but I
can only speak from my own perspective
ok and that also means if we don't
represent the perspective of the film
because maybe I should back up just a
tiny bit because the film was actually
sort of intended to mirror the processes
of the movement it was set up as a
parallel experiment so while we do have
experienced filmmakers leaving it if
there's all of these people all over the
country working on and making it so the
idea behind it is that it would have
many perspectives and that the many
perspectives together would form the
sort of most objective and complete
portraits of the movement itself so I
just have to say that when I say
anything I'm only talking for me Audrey
and not necessary for the entirety of
the silver the film's perspective sure
if that makes sense no it does that's
yeah that's an okay so how did the
movement start well America was in a
weird place I mean you were just we're
looking at a situation
the 2008 economic meltdown here in
America and around the world there were
just so many things that weren't working
for so many people and this Occupy
movement that came up in America is the
sort of American expression of a very
global movement and a global sentiment
you look at places like the Middle East
and you have the Arab Spring and you
look at Greece for there are fairy
lights you look at Spain and South
America and all these places that are
having movements of their own and
there's some there's a degree of
sympathetic movements where it's where
they occupy affiliated but regardless of
that it's the same kind of thing
happening around the world where people
are looking at a basic inequality and
just reaching a point where they don't
want things to continue business as
usual and I think that it's just one of
those big guys moments in history where
a lot of people are feeling the same
pressures and come together to do
something about it to create really
fundamental change sure anymore you
could look at it some fact that
basically a lot of people had be
sympathetic feelings and then adbusters
put out a call for an occupation and a
lot of people from various different
protest groups and different walks of
life decided okay let's make this happen
and they did uh-huh and who is the sort
of spearhead of the entire movement or
do we not know well if there were
there's a network of activist
organizations who in the u.s. a lot of
them were centered in New York and they
were getting together and actually
having planning meetings around this and
they were also working with people
around the world people in Spain people
in the Middle East people from UK and
cut and various groups who were together
working on building a sort of horizontal
democratic process and they had this
idea that they wanted to do a General
Assembly like the ones they've seen
Spain and in the Middle East and so
that's kind of what the whole idea is
centered
when adbusters made their called to
occupy wall street that acted like a
lightning rod and that was something
that people could just sort of focus on
and focus on energy storage and so that
I must have had an incredibly large role
in this whole thing actually taking off
them initially when people started
meeting to like plan what was going to
happen september's would meet up to the
call misses it was a variety of
different groups variety different
people who just came together started
meeting started planning okay and if
memory serves me right I believe that
the LA Occupy movement was sort of shut
down in november i believe of 2011 are
there others that are still in full
force or have they sort of been all shut
down throughout the country there are a
couple that still exist but i think that
a lot of people in the movement talk
about phase two and so after the
evictions in a lot of the major cities
you know the organizer started to
regroup and kind of get together around
planning sessions and ideas sessions and
going back to the sort of planning that
have been happening before the major
encampments and you know there's been a
lot of focus around May first in the g8
and NATO subnets and in Chicago and so
now we're just kind of looking and
waiting to see what happens with that
after the president announced that
they're removing the the GH to Camp
David instead of having it in a more
public space of Chicago so they had this
other focus for where you know they were
going to come out again and forth in a
very visible way so now it's just at
least from my perspective a kind of wait
and see what how they just got it okay
Aaron I mean how powerful is is this
movement is this the most powerful thing
of its kind that you've experienced in
your lifetime oh that I've experienced
myself like literally being there yeah
absolutely on the first time
that Audrey and I went was after the
first Brooklyn Bridge March were over
700 people were arrested very close to
apartments and we were watching it on on
livestream and the guys camera just sort
of blacked out and and uh because he ran
out of batteries and no one else was
covering it we tried to find someone
else covering it so we just decided you
know we have cameras we have lights for
filmmakers let's just go down and see
what's happening and it was just a it
was surprisingly powerful kind of
experience um so yeah definitely from my
perspective in my lifetime it is i mean
i can't speak for other major protest
movements that have gone before but for
me it's a definitely a unique experience
sure and why the Occupy movement of what
is it that either fascinates you or
fuels you I know you said that you're
not directly involved and I think that
was the same with your other film on the
Norwegian black metal that you were you
you weren't reverting churches or
anything right right now just for the
record right right and and and it's 22
because in reading some of this comments
people it seemed like they assumed that
you were supporters of this in in some
ways maybe on youtube or whatever but
you weren't you were just fascinated by
such a strange subculture so what is it
about the Occupy subculture if you want
to call it that well I mean I love us so
much there I personally find it very
difficult to either wholeheartedly
support or be against anything and that
was true of until the lights and the
black metal seeing that we were
profiling where there was a lot that I
had loved and respected about it and
then a lot that I disagreed with and I
said the same is true of the Occupy
movement I think that obviously they're
tapping into a lot of frustration and a
lot of issues that really need to be
addressed in Dallas and I think that a
lot of the core issues that couch time
has been does deal with their issues
that are very important to me and you
know I think that I've spent a lot of
time thinking about in and and he's home
being said about or etcetera and so we
and the movement actually started I
think that a lot of people around the
country just had a sense of oh they're
talking to all of these things that I've
been you know I've been dealing with and
I think that that just has a great
appeal for people to feel that not only
could they be heard but then other
people are actually saying the same
things that they're thinking that have
sort of been swept under the carpet I
mean when you have people like Mitt
Romney saying that you know cost work
there's a sort of thing that should be
talked about in back rooms but not
directly addressed I think that just
pisses people off in lightly show and I
think that a lot of people had just felt
silenced for a long time and the
movement was an avenue of expression and
of being heard and talking about things
that very they were very correct in that
these things needed to be addressed as a
culture and maybe it's a global culture
because businesses usual just has broken
down and the systems don't work for the
majority of people anymore you know I
guess the to help give this conversation
some perspective you know Audrey and air
you know where we're both of you like as
occupy wall street was was being
initiated and being you know and as
people started attending where we're
both of you in your lives you know cuz
all of a sudden you know here you are
your full steam ahead on this film
project but but where were you heading
into this movement while we were working
on dark places basically with a you know
someone in LA and basically like working
on what is fourth draft of that and
basically moving forward towards that
and we decided to put it on hold in
order to to do this and fortunately the
people who are working with were
amenable to that as well so dark ocean
is a thriller we had come off of sort of
finishing up a lot of the distribution
of until the light takes us and we're
prepping this thriller to go and and
then occupy started and I originally I
shouldn't have any intention to do
anything on it
I had absolutely no intention to
suddenly making a documentary film let
alone one that had like a hundred people
working on it she was just one of those
moments that was like you know when
Aaron was talking about the rest
happening on the Brooklyn Bridge you
know I was at home i was actually I so I
do you know outreach for indie films and
bands and things like that and I was
working on a film that was premiering in
London I was doing PR for that and I had
the live stream of the bridge on and and
just the fact that it wasn't on the news
that there were 700 kids being arrested
on a bridge in New York City it just
made me angry and I just wasn't prepared
to let that situation exists in the
world so that was what galvanized us
finally to go and you know check out
what was happening and because we're
filmmakers we check things out with
camera so you know I'm pretty much
instantaneously the idea was that okay
so we're going to do a project around
this we're going to document this and we
just felt that it should be documented
in a collaborative fashion that mirrored
the suburban itself we thought there was
a book of us interesting treatment and
also the one that you know it's
commander splint but as someone who's
not going to join a movement it was
almost a way of our version of
experiencing the movement in this I
really do call it a parallel experiment
to sort of see how the systems would
work in a real world example or model
and we found some very interesting
things by actually applying their model
to the filmmaking model I'm always
amazed when life just throws us these
curve balls in our let you know what we
think we have everything planned out
it's mapped out we're heading in a
certain direction and and the next thing
you know you just you know your fullest
your full steam ahead into something
like this I want to ask him it is there
any significance to the fact that occupy
wall street began ten years and one we
after 911 I never really thought about
it that way i I don't know I mean I
think it had more to do with this sort
of international scene and the fact that
there were these other movements who had
made calls for things like the day of
rage and that there were other kind of
protest movement and actual purchase DS
going on there was actually before
Occupy Wall Street there was another
call to occupy for august and like
nobody showed up no I'm not sure that
that's really excited would you say that
most of the people who attend the Occupy
protests are recently laid off or the
working poor or do they cross all class
levels are they really be across all
five levels I mean they're plenty of
people that we met there that we're not
in any way it seems adversely I'm get
some cinna photographers there who we
ended up working with as well I mean it
was no it's really impossible to just
generalize about the people that were
there they seemed to come from all you
know walks of life all different levels
of you know social the social strata
sure if that's one of the things that we
actually address in the film is we have
the film's organized around edge through
various directors are taking on various
aspects of the occupation or of the you
know the cultural environment for the
film and so Nina Christic is a director
who is directing the media and occupy
thread and so that's something she looks
at the way in which the media has
covered the movement and shelf is sort
of um I don't know really silly the
things that have been put out there
about you know and also it's a huge the
controller talking point as well
obviously that it's like hippies and
instruct ease I think right and I found
it interesting to listen to a lot of the
you know interviews as far as like the
people that were there and there was a
very sort of us versus them mentality
that if just the one percent would share
some of their wealth then we wouldn't be
in this situation and I realize that's
not sort of your job as filmmakers to
solve this problem or point blame but
from what I wasn't okay well that's
that's where i'm going with i'm curious
what what are your opinions on us
because i'm wondering if we're more it's
more of a collective problem people that
bought homes at the height of the market
and different things that happen or is
it sort of that us versus them mentality
that the the wealthy of gain control and
and we're feeling the effects of it um
so one of the things of making the film
that we've had this kind of deal with is
that there's so much complexity to these
issues and that's something that the
movement has dealt with by sort of
refusing to name specific demands to
refusing to distill it down to there's
one problem that if we fix this fix this
one problem everything else will fall
into place the movement is bringing
right to a kind of systemic failure
across the board of corruption on Wall
Street and in government where big money
is buying big favors and essentially
we've lost a representative government
and the ways in which that filters down
to sort of every level of society it's
kind of a huge problem I me nicely I
think the simple way to describe is I
think the problem is institutional it's
impossible to really separate one thing
the problem is systemic it's not the
entire system and I think their goal
more than to fix it was simply to get
people talking about it to open up a
dialogue of talking about the problem as
it exists as opposed to like talking
about oh we have like a major national
debt they want to like actually get
people talking about the problem as it
is and then try to go from there and
hopefully within the dialog some things
can be figured out and I think that the
dialogue that they started house
actually a major one um if you just
listen to the weight politicians talk
right now the things that they're saying
that they never would have said without
this movement and they really have sort
of like shifted the focus of how people
are looking at the problems financial
systems in our government are facing or
you need to face if not actually facing
them and and if this I know they say
we're out of a recession but if this
sort of low that we have we're still
jobs are just so scarce and money so
tight continues for many more years do
you think people would then turn very
very violent as in some other countries
he knows the seem to be more peaceful
but is do you think will reach a
breaking point um keep within the
movement in communion or the general the
general public yeah do you think that
that things could get more out of hand
it seems like this was a little more
controlled although I'm sure law
enforcement would not think that but do
you think we could ever reach a point if
years continue down the line we're still
in the situation and and you know we're
told continuously Oh it'll be you know
18 more months and then we'll see sort
of a spike in this and and it seems to
just be sort of dragging out and do you
think that people will tire of this and
become angry and they're already angry
but violent I think people are very
angry I think that people are trying to
channel their anger now and I think that
the Occupy movement has been very clear
about a stated principle of non-violence
and while there are some differences of
opinion between specific different
groups for instance we see a lot more
violence and have seen a lot more in
Oakland but there are a whole lot of
reasons for that it's it's very
complicated but it Oakland you have
people who have this this history of
resistance and a protest and as
progressive action you also have you
know a police force that's used to
dealing with a high crime area and you
have groups of black bloc anarchists who
have their own agenda so you have this
interesting mix of people in Oakland and
each occupation does have a
zone sort of make up like that but the
movement as a whole has a commitment to
non-violence because a lot of its appeal
our battle a lot of what I didn't talk
about is the idea that the public will
turn against them if they start swaging
a violent campaign and however that if
they remain non violent the police will
still respond in a violent fashion and
we've certainly seen that across the
country and that will point out some of
the problems and some of the the desire
of those in power to maintain control at
all costs and so they're very much
trying to stick to this nonviolent
tactic as a way of pointing out a
problem within the system as far as the
general public i don't know i think that
i don't know if that's really hard to
say I might I guess my gut says that we
probably are already seeing a bit more
violence but it's not organized I think
we're probably are seeing you know
crimes of desperation I don't know I
don't have any figures on there so I
can't really speak to it but yeah I mean
we're not you know yeah we're filmmakers
oh you know I can focus on the think I'm
making a film about and learned a lot
about that right now I'm focusing on the
problems with transcoding all different
kinds of cameras in the probability I
mean too much speculation is gonna have
me looking really powder you know but
that's perfect we're gonna start talking
more about the filmmaking you know and
in Audrey you said really the you know
seeing these 700 people arrested really
galvanized you and you just fell you you
had to do something about it so you know
here you are you have the idea to make
this film how long did you sort of wave
round the decision before you file
through it I mean it was this something
you wavered honors or something like you
know what
I'm a very impetuous person at times i
leap blindly into the projects because
it's the only way that I would ever do
it if I actually thought about the
ramifications of my actions of the
amount of work and I was going to have
to do and you have to eat dire
consequences it would have in my life I
would not make them so i think that i
just put on the blinders and leaps with
these things and that's exactly what i
did here I was pissed off that at the
way the media was handling it and so I
started a collaborative film I mean it
was because ramifications as soon as he
came up with the idea of the safely I'm
here and we're I mean we do the voice of
reason were you like hold on a second
here no I you know I thought it wasn't I
thought it was a good idea and I thought
that the I wasn't sure that they'd ever
actually been in a film made like this
with multiple directors multiple
perspectives I mean I know there have
been filmed with multiple directors were
it's sort of like shorts strung together
but actually we like a cohesive
narrative from a bunch of different
voices I thought that would be a real
challenge I mean I love making into the
light takes us and I love that film but
I thought if we were going to do another
doc like doing something interesting
with the form would be something that
really appealed to me so I yeah I did
recognize a secret number but I thought
it was a interesting kind of
collaborative experiment and that's
really sort of how I think of it as an
experimental film mm-hmm so once you
were all in and order you'd convinced
erinn to be a part of it what was the
first step what would you do him you
said you saw the sort of the protest
going on on the live stream and you were
angry become covered yeah sorry so
knowing like that the live stream they
cut out ice puts on the news it wasn't
on the news so Aaron and I went down
Zuccotti Park we film at night and then
the next day we started sort of you know
calling people and sunny on emails and
just getting in touch with sylvac
reference and saying hey we're going to
do this collaborative project on occupy
do you want to make a film
I said so men may reach out to their
friends if you liked our friends and we
had about 35 filmmakers at that point
involved and then we decided that if we
were really going to mirror them a bench
and do it in like a true parallel
experiment then we needed to open it up
to anybody who wanted to be involved and
that's where it really got fun we just
have had to forget out the word we had
some stuff and filmmaker magazine to New
York Times and and so through that
people started to get in touch with that
and people contacted a see our twitter
page so so one of the first things that
i did when i when i had the idea to
start the film was since i do a outrage
like instantly was like oh one we had a
website up and we had a twitter in a
facebook so there were these the
infrastructure was there for people to
reach us and it's so they started to and
within about a month we had around 60
people i think and then an hour around
100 Wow ya know it's amazing and and so
you know those initial 35 filmmakers
were they all based in New York City or
where they are already at the beginning
where they spread out all over the
country well they were mostly in New
York and LA right at first yeah yeah so
um so that was we did we need to we did
kind of put out the word that we were
interested in people in other places
also you know working with us though
you say you have what almost 100
filmmakers involved with the project how
do you go about selecting the filmmakers
where there's some that you decided not
to use or some a little too militant for
you or just I mean it's a meta sort of a
marriage I mean you have to be able to
cooperate so what was your screening
process well it was an interesting thing
that happened for the most part people
self-selected themselves out there were
a couple people who didn't sort of work
very well with the group and there were
people who were interested in propaganda
and only interested in propaganda by
which I mean they were only interested
in a favorable depiction of the
movements and so that was just something
that I said as a guideline in advance
that we are not doing propaganda okay
then we will not sort of allow that that
sort of perspective to take control of
the project it's not worth doing a film
to me if it's propaganda I'm not
interested in that I'm interested in you
know doing something that sheds light
and and brings contacts and you need to
be honest that's actually happened and
you know the movement certainly has
warts and this is reality it's real life
of course so people who didn't like that
left and at the same time people who
were very very critical also tended to
leave because most people in the film
you know to some degree relates to the
movement whether they're part of it or
not you know I don't think too many of
us have health insurance for instance
hmm so there's like a baseline of where
if you're young in in America and
working in creative pursuits there's a
certain second-class citizenship that
goes along with that oh sure you know we
don't have access to basic services
right right I'm wondering how oh I'm so
sorry I so you these people seems like
they've sort of weeded themselves out
did you have to cut ties and if so how
do you do that
and can't even say the word but it's
almost like lending a bad relationship
so how do you do that how do you cut
ties and and make sure that no one's to
disgruntled if that's possible I'm
actually care about people okay I'm
perfectly fine with telling people where
to take it okay there jerky or whatever
was I making films is really really
really hard as anybody who actually make
some knows and I don't have time for a
lot of and I don't have
patience for a lot of so for me
it's kind of like you're either here to
work and this is going to be work or if
you're not able to then you know go home
how do you have gathered from you may
have gathered from our thoughts comments
that one way are some differs from
different it is our film is not a
leaderless movement okay perfect her no
and their how stupid I was actually yeah
that was the best part of the process
the experimental process of you know
figuring out so we were sort of taking
the the Occupy process and trying to
apply it to a realized model of where
you couldn't have known these people you
know working together or something but
when we turned it into this thing of
where we have an actual goal a specific
goal which is to make a feature film
that can actually be seen by a wide
audience and that will you know have
value to the larger society etc but also
be of a certain professional quality and
we quickly found that you simply do not
make films by committee there can be
collaborative aspects to it but it must
have leaders so specific there for
instance Oh Nina like they really did
sort of self select in a way I mean some
people wanted to you know just go film
when they wanted to film and then they
were happy with that other people wanted
to pledge their skills other people with
Nina Christic is doing the media thread
that I'll just talk about this came and
said I want to do something more here's
my idea and we're like great and we
hooked her up with other different
people who would like
then and you know there's basically it
really did sort of come together in a
kind of organic way with people once we
basically understood what different
people were willing to pledge and what
they wanted to do it was just a matter
of organizing nothing not to minimize
how much recognizing it but but and for
people who didn't want to make a huge
commitment there was space for that also
you know people were absolutely able to
just show them some things in and then
you know we would either use it or not
but people who wanted to work more
directly and collaboratively and making
the film you know we all talked about
what should this film be and so the
whole group had this discussion early on
about what should the fill me in that
and so we made an outline about what
topics the film should cover and then
people stepped forward to cover to
direct the threads members or other
people said you know I just I filmed
this rally and I'm going to send it it
and that's my contribution and that's
totally fine as well so it is a mix and
it is arranged but if people did step
forward and take responsibilities and we
very much expected that to be respected
because this is a lot of work and so
that was sort of an issue that came up
with having non-professionals work on
the film is I think a lot of people have
this idea that filmmaking is something
you can do sort of heaven I don't know
in a very serious way yeah and so that
was a problem at times where people
would take responsibility and step
forward and want it and then not be able
to fulfill that Shema and that's the
sort of thing that we've just had to
deal with that Muslims don't have to
right right well this question comes in
from Marty Lang and it ties into what
you'd said earlier about people wanting
to be part of it for their own agenda
and sort of spreading propaganda and he
says my question to Audrey and Erin
would be has it been a challenge
maintaining objectivity throughout the
making of the project if I was making
something like this I would have a
really hard time keeping my own wildly
liberal ideas out of things looking
forward to your in
it's so horrible so hi Marty yeah and so
that's sort of one of the interesting
things about this I kind of don't have
to in that with all these other voices
my voice can be heard without taking
over the project or taking over the
perspective I happen to be one of the
more cynical people on the phone isn't
so the good thing is that the film will
not be a cynical hatchet peace not that
it would be you know but it can be even
if I wanted to do that I couldn't do it
with all these other people's voices in
it so but that was part of the idea
going in is that may be the closest
thing to a subjective portrait or simply
inject a fortune would be a multitude of
subjectivity 'he's so i don't have to
not be the cynical dark bitter soul that
I am I can still be that and also make a
multi-faceted film about this and to be
honest even if we weren't making it this
way it's really the kind of film that
I'd want to see about this I mean I'm
sick the movie itself is so big and so
widespread and and and cover so many
different groups of people and things
that just having sort of one person's
analysis on it is it's kind of just
institution you know I'm just imagining
this I mean a hundred filmmakers about
how do you begin to divide up the work
you know you have a hundred people
committed to shooting footage I mean how
do you do how do you divide they're not
all they're not all necessarily shooters
I mean sometimes and sometimes like say
someone is a shooter and they're like
well I want to help on this but I'm not
really going to be you know doing any
investigation on my own so give me a
call if you need someone to go help
shoot you know we there's really a lot
of different levels of commitment and a
lot of different skills that different
people have you know so it's more than
just people strictly shooting
I mean I actually I post-production
supervisor just showed up here right now
with the transcode for us I mean like
use this people that are helping in a
variety of ways I mean making films
takes a ton of skills and many more than
just being able to go someone point of
camera oh yeah we've got um you know a
couple of our people like ginger Lou in
LA who does PR an outreach she's working
we have a few PRN outreach people and
have you know my friend and filmmaker
who I really respect David Duvernay you
know she sent us a hard drive and she
was hoping to have some time to work and
there's i should mention she just won be
a best director award at sundance very
talented woman and you know we have
Stephen Dotson and Kerry Collins you
know are winning our Twitter and there's
a girl in Montreal who's running our
Facebook we've got some great web
designers Matt walgreen Jeremy King once
in Tokyo ones in Brooklyn so we have
like a whole team pal humanitarian
editors yeah so there's just as all
kinds of people want year in the fill in
all kinds of capacities Aaron llanes
supervising editor is just phenomenal
and then I leave editor Thailand walk is
as well as working through the key to
the next room working so I could keep
going you know it's like there's so many
of us all doing different things and and
when you get so many people that are a
sense you know helping you to
crowdsource this material you know is
there any compensation expected on the
back end or or or is this is everyone
just literally volunteering their
efforts in their time you know to get
this film eight well I don't really
think of it as crowdsourcing I really do
think it as collaborating where people
can take as a bigger smaller role as
they want to I mean it's really more
targeted than that like expect that
you know like say we have someone in New
York who wants an interview for their
thread and a subject is found in
California so the way it works is you
know Audrey will get in touch with the
subject and we'll find filmmakers in
California filmmaker New York will read
their questions and say what they want I
mean it's not really crowdsourcing it
really is a collaboration that sort of
stretches across the nation and its it's
targeted filming it's not really so much
looking for stuff it it's connecting
people and people collaborate and meet
and that's one of the greatest things
about a project is all the people that
we've met doing it that are awesome so
were there any scary sort of close calls
during the filming either from
yourselves or someone else or maybe law
enforcement got mad if someone was
filming them got arrested ok welcome has
been very mad many times that we've been
told okay well one of us filmmakers
Gretchen she was actually arrested and
she's having to deal with that process
it looks like they're gonna throw it out
but shadows Abby's been tougher sprayed
yeah Abby Martin our director and in
Oakland she's been pepper-sprayed
multiple times I've been pepper sprayed
with jen cox one another where my
cinematographers in New York I was also
almost arrested while filming an arrest
there's have been this whole thing of
where the police have very actively
tried to borrow fresh and people with
cameras from filming you know most of
what they do so when there was a point
after the eviction in New York like
right after where I was trying to film
them arresting the girl and the cops
start getting she'll be with me and I do
what you're not supposed to do which is
pop back the cops and so I did I told
him I had a right to film and he really
didn't like that at all so he starts
grabbing my camera and all the cops are
shoving and I just been talking to one
of the National Lawyers Guild guys for a
while and so he was right there and
Aaron
behind me so I had people yelling on my
behalf and then the cops the cops saying
you know I had people saying she's
precious products and Men the cops
yelling when she press passes you know
it was just kind of as crazy scene and
then I felt someone grabbing my camera
which I had above my head I was filming
the whole time and I was like oh
photo shoot I'm so sorry I can't answer
sorry I just thought died oh no that
he's had a lot of sense oh yeah ok ok ya
know how much so I felt someone's I
being the camera and I was like oh no so
trying to get it I like held on for dear
life it was like you might get me but
you're not getting my camera and then I
kind of realized that it was in behind
me trying to grab me and pull me back
out of the fray and so I kind of got out
of that one what other filmmakers have
been thrown by the police and the
cameras have been broken jaw and John we
had Scott Campbell and again in Oakland
was actually shot by a police officer he
was he was not doing anything at all he
was filming and he was shot and what
happened to win the way you know he had
image was a rubber ball third ok exactly
but um yeah no I mean this has really
been one of those we're putting
ourselves out there a lot of people are
putting themselves out there to cover
this so now you have a current indiegogo
crowdfunding campaign where do things
stand with the film and and tell us more
about the campaign well we just started
this in together campaign they're kind
of a rough time because we're scrambling
to get an added together a rough cut to
both to bring to the funders to try and
get some real funding in here and and
you know doing all the sort of some
things that have to happen and at the
same time we just keep running on a hard
drive mmm it's like I think for broke in
the last week we're sending them around
the country picking up footage and then
that's not really supposed to you know
hard drives not really built for that
but so we're doing retire then there's
also like just constant storage needs
having so many editors it means we need
to have all these hard drives and that
is just so much material so you know
it's just as a constant kind of thing
for us and then just making films costs
money so yeah we have an IndieGoGo
campaign up we've come to successful
Kickstarter campaigns and again that was
the most recent one we raised about
twenty thousand dollars and so one of
our contributors Billy is a curator so
he curated all of this art for us and
all these amazing artists donated
artwork to him so we had sort of a
campaign built around that and so for
the one right now where we're kind of
trying to do it at the same time as
we're trying to do all these other
things so we've just started it and
we're just we're really hoping that you
know I personally don't have a time this
time to do outreach really so we're
hoping that we're kind of out there to a
degree in that people will I don't know
find us this one isn't the most
sought-out thing to be honest we're just
like shoot me we need an influx of cash
and and hopefully people will support it
and people can still submit their
content to you is that right you're
still looking for collaborators or is
that close I agree but it's very
targeted now it's like there's we can
reach the limit of where we can just
take random footage so it really has to
be specifically targeted to something
that we know we want or something that
we can tell will fit it's just that
there's a time limit how much time we
can actually go through all this footage
yeah I were in it we're in the edit at
this point too so I mean you know the
film is you know more or less getting
structured right now so it's we're
pretty much we're not completely in post
i would say but we're you know have more
than one toe in the waters of
post-production okay and you're still
working you have your own jobs outside
of this as well oh so every
actually this was so sad in a way so
Aaron had just taken a job working on
another film so he is right now editing
a documentary about TI like all day
every day and then he comes home and he
works on this like late and then all
weekend and it's just one of those
things where he'd already made a
commitment somewhere else and there's
really no getting around that and also
there's reg and so is really like
pushing the exhaustion wall to the point
that is heroic yeah a lot of walks
around the block will help with that
just like this make you squeal actually
turned toward red bull as our Savior
actually i-i've red bull was just a
gateway for me it moved on to five hour
energy oh wow okay there's a tolerance
level with that yeah we want to thank
you both for joining us here are film
purse today and we want to thank you for
your efforts and getting this film made
and we're really looking forward to
following the progress and seeing the
finished product when it's all said and
done yeah we sure are and curious to
like in 20-30 years because you know
what what you know it's just sort of
like the Kent State shooting and
different things and what this film will
be in 20-30 years sometimes you can't
see stuff until it's further down the
line so fascinated by God we might oh go
ahead oh just you know I was just gonna
say thanks for having us and certainly
were hopeful that we can do something
that adds to the conversation sounds
like you're definitely doing that yeah
and we've enjoyed this conversation
we've been speaking with Audrey you'll
and Aaron eighths of ninety-nine percent
the Occupy Wall Street collaborative
film for more on Audrey and Aaron please
visit their IndieGoGo campaign at
indiegogo com / 99 film also the film
site at 99 and that's the numbers 99%
film.com facebook.com slash 99% film and
Twitter at 99 underscore film and you
know if you want to see their previous
work
film until the lights until the light
takes us and you can find that at black
metal movie com also check out the
article by Williams Cole one of the
collaborators on 99 percent and it's an
article on film courage calm entitled
filmmaker ego check important essential
and just nuts regarding his involvement
with 99 percent thank you once again for
spending time with us today Audrey and
Aaron yeah thank you so much haven't yet
absolutely I also thank you to Ronan
here at la talk radio he built film
courage calm force and he runs the board
at the station as well and he is an
integral essential part of what we do
here and we would be totally lost
without him Thank You Ronnie would you
like to hear your project or business
mention during one of our shows or
displayed on our site to advertise with
film courage calm and our radio program
please inquire through film courage calm
via our contact page next Sunday we have
another fascinating story you may have
heard of them um you know we have a very
fastening story of two brothers Franz
and Kurt wisner and their book honeymoon
with my brother yeah and it was a slated
maybe to be a movie and we're curious to
hear more about it it's a true-life
account of Franz who unfortunately was
left a week before his wedding by his
bride-to-be and received a work demotion
from his real estate job at the same
time Franz decided not to cancel the
wedding instead turning it into a party
and he kept them honeymoon reservations
went on the honeymoon with his brother
Kurt until broke until both brothers
realized that they wanted to sell their
homes and see the world for a few years
both brothers tied up loose ends and
settled their financial affairs
traveling the world to discover the true
meaning of love for more about this
incredible story please visit honeymoon
with my brother calm and Frances latest
project how the world makes love calm
until next Sunday have a great week
you